Well, welcome everybody to another film call and we're going to get started.
All right.
Reminder to everybody to look at the updates on the member site Thursday,
for this week.
But we will be, I will be missing two Zoom calls in the next two months.
One in the week from next week.
And then one in July.
I will close that when those in closing were done.
All right.
First question.
Let's jump into this.
On the mosaic microtox profile.
How would you treat someone with a high aquatoxin A?
Well, aquatoxin A is a microtoxin.
Let's just, let's just remind everybody that we're talking about the microtoxins.
We're talking about poisons that that microtox that molds give off.
So when you have an elevated microtoxin any of the microtoxins that the microtoxin tests for.
That doesn't mean that you have active mold growing inside your body.
Make sure you look at the blog posts that I have on this to help you understand what about the microtoxin test is.
So these are poisons and these are poisonous to everybody.
They're not something to be taken lightly.
They're not something to pretend it's not going to hurt you.
These are some things that are serious.
It will also tell you that.
The.
In that.
Well, they have test if you read down.
So this is an example test here.
I have shown here on the slide where it shows I think it's on page two of the microtoxin test profile.
Then it gives you the summary of the different microtoxins that are elevated.
And then as you scroll down, it gives you the value on page three or five, six, seven, eight.
All the different microtoxins that were tested.
And then if we get you get down into the interpretation guide of the test, it tells you where you would pick up these toxins.
What molds give off these toxins because different molds give off different toxins.
So if you have these toxins, you got it from a mold.
Where did you get the mold?
Well, you could have got it from foods that you ate that had that mold.
And then they were producing microtoxins and then you consumed them, or you could have got them from breathing.
Just how do you get any toxins in your body?
They have to either they have to cross a barrier talk talk to spill gasoline on your skin.
It crosses the skin barrier and absorbs through your skin.
Then you absorb it through your skin barrier.
If you swallow something and it got went across your got border and that it was absorbed into your tissues and to your bloodstream, then it went across the got border.
If you breathe them in, then it goes across your lung border.
What's the fastest way to get any toxin in your body?
Question?
Any answers?
The answer is, um, injected.
So injected in your body.
So you're taken injection of a poison that's fastest way to get the poison into your bloodstream, just inject it right into the bloodstream.
And the fastest way to kill a person is by injecting them with the poison.
So second fastest way to get a toxin in your body, the easiest border to cross is the lung board.
So though, if you look at that mycotoxin profile, you could say, well, maybe I'm getting it from all the peanuts that I'm eating.
Well, that's possible.
Could you get mycotoxins from peanut butter that was made in a factory that the peanuts were moldy and it producing mycotoxin and then they.
And then you ate the peanut butter?
Well, sure, that could be a source of mycotoxins.
So people are addicted to peanut butter.
Maybe a good idea to get a mycotoxin test every once in a while to make sure that you're not over dosing yourself with mycotoxins and poisoning yourself.
Because you'll see some of the things that these mycotoxins can cause.
And, you know, there are all sorts of bad things, but one of the things that mycotoxins can cause is cancer.
Most of the mycotoxins are carcinogens, not all of them, but they're carcinogens.
And we can't say without, you know, reasonable doubt that this, you know, person has elevated mycotoxins and they have cancer that the two necessarily quarreling.
But it's something that we do address.
So, but the most common way we get mycotoxins is from mold growing in our homes or our workspaces or in, you know, a meeting hall that we go to or a church that we go to regularly, that's mold.
So, the fastest way to get things toxins into our body, other than injecting them is through our nasal passives and through our lungs absorb it them through the other spaces, it's the bloodstream.
So, and the quantity of mycotoxins that you can get breathing them in is much greater than eating, if you're eating peanuts or corn.
You can get mycotoxins from those things too.
So, in your mycotoxin profile, if you read down, you can see different sources.
It doesn't tell you treatment parameters. So, what would you do to help pull mycotoxins out of your body?
Well, you want to use a key later. So, there's different key laders on the market and the key later that I, several key laders that I like.
One of the key laders that I like is this HM ET binder. So, this HM ET binder from cell core is a great key later for cancer patients for all sorts of different toxins.
Cell core makes some really good products.
We have them on our store. It has humic acid and folic acid. It has zeolite. And it has broccoli sprow extract.
That's a good binder for glyphosate. This is a good binder and a key later for mycotoxins. So, but again, how do you get any toxins out of your body?
You don't just like, okay, we're going to key later out of our body. You do so by supporting the detoxification catalyst.
So, you're supporting your liver function, you're supporting your liver detoxification pathways when you support and increase the rate of detoxification.
And also decrease the rate of toxification of other things, meaning you clean up your diet.
So, many times the reason why we're not detoxifying either mycotoxins or heavy metals or anything is that we're, we're toxifying ourselves at a greater rate that our liver could handle getting rid of things.
So, let me give you an example. If we're like eating a crappy diet or we're not taking care of ourselves, a rate of toxins that is coming into our body can exceed the rate of our ability to get rid of them through the liver.
And when we do that, then those toxins can't stay in the blood because they will kill us. So, they're shunted to the extracellular spaces and then they end up within the cells in our cell store toxins.
And the most common cell that stores toxins that seem to have a gift through accommodation are fat cells and fat cells, so are the organs. And that's not good.
Because that can cause that can end up toxins within a cell and then damage the nucleus, the replication rate and the cause of cancer, the most commonly causing cancer's toxins.
Is it like with toxins? Well, it's any toxins. All sorts of thousands and thousands of different poisons that were exposed to an, an annual basis.
And the less exposure you could have to those things, the better you're going to, I mean, we all want to go, how do we increase our detox? How do we support detox? And how do I support my liver?
Well, it's wise to, to do things to support your liver and support upon one pathway and the, in a tea pathway and the, and the side from people for 50 pathway in the liver.
If you don't decrease the rate of hawksification, we're never going to win the battle.
So make sure that you're, you're cleaning up your diet. Well, mostly everybody on this call is doing that. They've cleaned up their diet. They're trying to eat right there. Stayed away from glyphosate.
They're staying away from toxic metals and colorings and food additives and flavorings and all that kind of garbage.
Well, now it's time to just use a key later. So I would use this HMET and take, I would really just start off taking maybe one a day of this, and that can be very beneficial.
First, I asked another question about glyphosate test of having an elevated glyphosate test. This is not their test. This is sample test.
But I would, again, I would use the HMET, that's a nice thing about that is it will not, it's not specific to any given toxins. So I mean, we're only testing here glyphosate in glycol toxins, but that's not saying you don't have heavy metal toxins.
And, you know, food coloring toxins and any a myriad of other different places in your tissues. Well, this isn't going to be specific to any of them. That's what I told you long ago.
So start off taking one a day and tolerate that just fine. It doesn't, you know, make you a little sluggish or anything, which is typically well, you can go up to two a day. Typically, it'll be more.
If someone, for someone who is estrogen receptor positive, taking an asterisk song, what supplements might help come back? Join me.
Even though it is prescribed daily, I wonder about taking a lower dose combined with a supplement.
Yeah, the problem with doing a estrogen blocker is that you do get, you get symptoms because, you know, people think, oh, my hormones are only for, you know, certain functions of my body.
They don't realize that your hormones really helped with this overall systemic balance of health in your body. And when you decrease estrogens dramatically in a relatively short period of time, you can end up with all sorts of weird symptoms.
And joint pain and skin issues and all sorts of things go along with it.
Trying to deal with it from a comorbidity standpoint can be helpful. One thing that can be helpful is the taking more increasing your flavonoids, which would be the curcumin, green tea extract.
Varatrol, stinging nettles, corsets, and that can help with pain, that can help with, with, with us, peripheral inflammation that can go along with decreasing estrogens.
Certainly, you can talk to your doctor about decreasing your dosage. Remember, whatever they're dosing you on these things, they're giving you just the standard dosage that comes along with, with their electronic work manual.
They're not really treating you as an individual. You have to ask for it.
So ask that, hey, I want to go down on my dosage and see if it works the same way, if it's still decreasing my estrogens. And if they push back at that, and they say, well, no, we, we have to use this dosage because this is what's really going to work.
Then say, then say, okay, I want you to measure it then. I want you to measure my estrogen, do a blunt test, measure your estrogen levels.
And if it's down in the pits like they want it to be, then let's go a lower dose and let's measure it again and see if it's still down in the pits.
You got to push for the care that you want.
You know, you know, that's, you have to take charge of your care like that. So that's what I would suggest. I think you're right on the right track.
Remember, ask this question. You ask questions on of your prescribing doctor and see if you can get a different dosage. I think that's good.
Oh, you're, I recently read your piece on how does glutamine feed cancer? It had a couple of questions.
Number one, my doctor recently put me on sodium fetal muterate as a metabolic blockade of glutamine.
Does this accomplish the same thing as glutamate scavenger two?
So the easy answer that is no, it doesn't do the same thing as glutamate scavenger two glutamate scavenger two helps get rid of glutamate.
So understand there's a difference with glutamine and glutamate glutamine converts to glutamate and glutamate to glutamine in the body.
But they are two different things. Glutamate is not a feeder of cancer.
Glutamine is a fuel source of cancer, can be a fuel source of cancer. Glutamate is a neurotransmitter that is a derivative of glutamine.
So I know it gets a little confusing, but they're two different molecular structures. Now there is a gene called your dad genes that converts this that controls the conversion of glutamine to glutamine.
So buterates in your gut will help with the overall absorption of glutamine, which is good.
So taking both of these things would be the right thing to do.
Well, let's go to the second question here. The bottle does not indicate the timing is the glutamate is the glutamate scavenger best taken with animal proteins at bedtime to support the cleanup process during sleep.
So glutamate scavenger does not work in the gut. So it's not blocking absorption of amino acid glutamine.
It's helping get rid of glutamates in the tissues and in the brain.
So taking it during the day, you know, spreading it out during the day, anytime during the day with meals or without meals, it doesn't make any difference because you're trying to get rid of glutamates.
Now why would you get rid of glutamates if, you know, I don't have problems with glutamates.
Well, it would be evidence of somebody having a problem with glutamates. Well, glutamates can convert back to glutamine.
So as person with cancer that has none of the symptoms that I'm going to talk about in a second here, can still convert glutamate to glutamine.
And can glutamates can be a fuel source of cancer.
However, a person can have issues with glutamates and not have issues with glutamate, meaning they don't have cancer.
They're taking glutamate further, got, they don't have an issue quote unquote with glutamate, but person with a lot of bad defects that gene can convert glutamate to glutamate quite quickly.
There's a lot of people in that cave and glutamate excess is a huge problem in the world because of a few reasons.
But glutamate excess could cause a lot of emotional imbalance. So glutamate is a neurotransmitter, like I said, but it's an excitatory neurotransmitter.
It's not regulates the brain. Now it's a necessary neurotransmitter. It's the neurotransmitter that helps you wake up in the morning and get you going.
It's a neurotransmitter that gives you drive and helps you think and process information, but excess glutamate can cause excess drive and OCD type symptoms in anxiety type symptoms.
And that is a big problem in our society.
So excess glutamate is not good.
Access glutamate in different forms can even be worse and cause brain inflammation. It can be a cause of damage to microglial cells in the brain as well.
That's why you want to really be careful of food consumption that has stimulatory glutamates in it.
Namely, MSG. So MSG, the reason why they put modusodium glutamate in foods is because it makes the food taste better.
Well, let's reframe that. It really doesn't make the food taste better. It makes you think the food taste better.
That's exactly what it does.
Because it stimulates glutamate receptors on your tongue, which fire glutamate receptors in your brain, exciting your brain, making you think, wow, these Doritos are so good.
Oh my gosh, these are so delicious. Give me another one. They sell more Doritos that way.
Stimulating your brain to make you think that the food is delicious because it's exciting your brain.
Well, you continue to overexcite your brain with excess amount of glutamates consumed.
You can burn neurons and that is one leading cause of early dementia.
So having excess glutamates, not good for microglial driving, not good for early dementia issues and something you really want to be careful with with cancer because excess glutamates can also convert back to glutamate.
So long story is glutamate and glutamate are different, but they're interchangeable because they can convert back and forth.
The different products that will decrease glutamates can be beneficial for cancer patients, because it can decrease the amount of glutamate.
But there's other things that can help decrease the absorption of glutamate glutamate and certainly dietary restriction of excess glutamate is is a smart thing to do.
You would mutate and scavenger and anyway compete with each other. No, totally different things. They're both to be beneficial.
I also saw glutamate scavenger three. No, you tested for glutamate scavenger two.
Okay, questions on the chat. Last week I asked your opinion of participating in a clinical trial and logged into the zoom call just as you were mentioning the question. Yes.
And then we didn't get a recording last week because my power we had a storm and literally it was just we were just about ready to finish the call.
And all of a sudden our power went out in our house.
So we take it recorded.
So should a person the question was participating in a clinical trial. What do I think about participating in clinical trials?
I don't think participated in clinical trial wrong at all. I think it's wrong. If you don't, if for you certainly would be wrong, you are doing everything you can naturally.
But when you hear a person that's, you know, you know, getting a very grave diagnosis, they've never even explored any natural things.
And let's say it's a diagnosed that chemotherapy doesn't work well on. Let's say they have a, you know, cancer with a very low success rate with genital therapy with state other standards of care.
And they're offered a clinical trial and they're considered immediately without trying natural things. I think that's kind of foolish.
But if you're exhausting everything and you're doing everything in there, have some problems in a clinical trial that you feel like God is leading you that that might be an answer by all means. I think you could pray about it.
But if you feel like God is opening the door or something, I think there's anything wrong with to walk you down that.
Will there be any discounts in the store this month, like possibly the 4th of July.
I do not know we haven't discussed that at all. Possibly, possibly. Well, I will, if we, if there are, I'll put it up on the member side right after talking to this morning.
I remember taking my omid in the past, and it seems to agree with me. What's your opinion on that? Well, my omid is a supplement that will help balance and decrease bad estrogen. So absolutely.
It's a Chinese, my omid is a Chinese herb that my omid is the brand. Dr. Cheese, I think that's the brand. And it's a good thing. I mean, I, I know I've muscles has to be for it in the past in it or good. So I think that would be a good thing to take.
The aroma clear is different. So aroma clear is different than my omid. So I think I think I think taking the bolt would be good.
So you don't see that in the store. Yes, it's this, it should be that HMET binding. Yes.
Yep, it's this second one was HMET perfect. Any other questions.
So good with medication. Well, the side effects appear and worsen with time.
They can. Yes.
Which I could say don't, but they can. Oh, I don't want to put something in your head because maybe they won't with you.
So I do think when you decrease four bones dramatically, the biggest change in symptoms comes immediately.
But over time, you can have some deterioration of tissues like, like we discussed before, like hand.
I mean, it's called the hand syndrome or something that comes with decrease in hormones.
And, and some joint issues are really common with decrease in hormones.
And that speaks to that question that we had earlier, another thing that can be good for that besides lavender, and, and anti-inflammatories can be.
It's related. B6 can be helpful as well. But I would treat it as symptoms appear. So good news.
I'm happy for you there. I don't remember you mentioned in my moment to me before as a suggested supplement. Oh, I just, I thought you were taking it before and I tested you quite a bit somebody else.
But I thought you were taking it. We have another people that are taking one of it.
I would just go ahead without us testing. I think that's a safe thing. It's not like it's a specific cancer killer or something you're trying to get it here.
To balance.
You're on your forehead. So I said that would be starting to take care of.
And lip tilts are palpably smaller than it's raised the Lord. I mean, don't think, you know, I haven't.
Shared is reminder to all of us to be afraid for each other. You know, everybody's going through their struggles here, obviously. That's why there are this call.
And we need to be, you know, having, you know, knowing that we all got each other's back. And we're all praying for each other for healing for God's plan to be manifested in their life.
That we can have eyes to see what God's purpose is, even in our struggles and our suffering.
You know, Jesus learned through his suffering by the says. And so do we, we're not any less than that.
All of them probably suffered more than anybody on earth. What he went through.
That is Lisa's right down and we know about is, is, you know, you can just constantly praise God through that.
And we need to have that ability to do that too. We could only do that. So we embrace a God. So we prayed for God's grace for each other in everything that we're going through for God's wisdom.
To understand the sovereignty and pray for just his blessing that we can have peace that surpasses all human understanding.
Nobody else would ever stand peace that we have points to the struggles that we have because we're trusted in real aid of God.
And remember that everything that God puts us through, there's a purpose that the purpose is to drive his us closer to him.
He loves us so much. He loves us to be communicating with him and talking to him throughout the day. That's what called it by say that we should be prayed unceasingly.
As we were on our knees with our hands folded always said we're always communicating with him. He's not just our God, but she is there as our friend as our mate as our
We were purchased by him. We are just right. And and be more and more dependent on our kids. We learn through life. That is what sanctification is. And we learn to struggles and we learn to operate so pray for all of us. That's my prayer for you.
It's that while here's our verse of our day, the man who endured trials, stood the test to receive the prayer of life which God has promised us.
Okay, last call for questions. All right, God bless you guys. We'll see you next week. And I think it's the week after that. We'll be putting on.
All right, God bless everybody. Bye bye.